[Music]
on august 4th this warehouse in beirut
lebanon caught fire
when the fire spread through the
building this happened
all of a sudden i could hear glass
shattering
and then there was dust everywhere the
fire detonated about 2 700 metric tons
of ammonium nitrate a highly explosive
material that was stored here in the
port of beirut
the explosion leveled the port and left
a zone of destruction six miles wide
killing nearly 200 people and wounding
thousands
so this explosion just turned into what
resembles frankly like a war zone
it was catastrophic i still can't get
the pictures out of my head to this day
every single day somebody else is being
varied
for lebanon this was just one more
catastrophe
to an already perfect storm long before
the explosion
lebanon's economy was in a deep crisis
unemployment and poverty were on the
rise
and people flooded the streets in
outrage over and over again
for many the explosion was the last draw
so how did lebanon fall so far and what
can be done to fix it
the first thing to understand is the
makeup of lebanon's population
for centuries it's been home to both
christians and muslims
but communities are further divided into
religious subgroups or sects
the largest being maronite christians
and sunni and shia muslims
in the mid 20th century these three
sects shared power but there is a
tension between them
in 1975 maronite and muslim militias
sparked a civil war
lebanon a country now torn in two by the
vicious battle for supremacy between
christians and muslims
two dozen cease-fires have been agreed
and broken
soon other sects formed militias and
joined the conflict in 1976
syria invaded and in 1982 israel
followed
fueling more violence fighting was
particularly brutal in beirut which was
divided among the militias
the muslims control west route the
christians are entrenched in the east
the toll of human life is horrifying
over the course of 15 years more than
120 000 people died
finally in 1989 representatives of
lebanon sex came together
with other international leaders to end
the war
they signed the type agreement which
divided the government among the sects
in parliament each group received a set
number of seats and specific positions
the president would be ameronite the
prime minister a sunni
and the speaker of the parliament ashiya
shortly after signing the agreement most
of the militias disbanded
but many of their leaders found a place
in government
in this system political parties were
formed along religious lines
and each sect claimed different
government ministries while it was meant
to
kind of smooth or transition the country
into a
post-conflict scenario it actually
allowed the conflict to persist by other
means
but this system wasn't designed to be
permanent the idea was that within three
years
of the thrive agreement the actual
governance of the country would move
towards a non-sectarian system
that bit was never implemented instead
the politicians separated their portions
of government
and turned them into fiefdoms using them
to enrich themselves and their sex
they use them for patronage to provide
jobs
to siphon off funding from state coffers
and it allows the political leadership
to perpetuate their control
over their constituencies while using
public money for personal gain
the politicians neglected to spend money
on the services they were supposed to
provide
like garbage collection a report found
that lebanon was paying about 420
million dollars a year for waste
management
despite that in 2015 garbage piled up
around the country while politicians
argued over a new contract
it was the same story across the
government it spent one billion dollars
a year on electricity
a sector controlled by the maronites but
there were blackouts multiple times a
day
every household paid a fee for public
water but much of it was undrinkable
by 2015 discontent against government
corruption was on the rise
but nothing changed demanding for
example to put someone in jail because
they were corrupt
immediately became as if it was an
attack against the entire
community it became very difficult to
undertake
any kind of changes or reforms and that
meant the same people stayed in power
so government corruption continued to go
unchecked
over time the government racked up
dangerous amounts of debt by 2015 it
owed nearly 70 billion dollars
more than the country's entire gdp but
instead of trying to fix the problem
the government turned its attention to
lebanon's most important industry
so since the end of lebanon civil war
1990
lebanon's economy in general has mostly
been service based we don't produce a
lot here
we are a heavy heavy importing country
we import food we import raw material we
import a lot of things
lebanon's businesses pay for imports
with us dollars which they get through
the banks
and lebanon's banks famously offer high
interest rates which attract deposits
from clients
all over the world making it the most
important sector in lebanon
most of the banks are owned by or have
ties to sectarian politicians
and together they created a scheme to
bring more money into the government
it started with the central bank which
funds the government offering very high
interest rates as an incentive to
commercial banks
so these banks deposited money there and
made a huge profit from the interest
in turn the banks hiked their own
interest rates even higher to attract
deposits around the world
and then poured that money into the
central bank
but this was unsustainable neither the
banks nor the government could really
cover
all this interest it's quite accepted
that it's a bit of a ponzi scheme
encouraging people to put their money in
the banks and keep them there because of
high interest rates knowing that the
banks
don't might not be able to maintain that
is a rip-off
the only thing keeping this scheme
together was the bank's ability to
attract more and more money
and that started to crack in 2011 when
lebanon's neighbor syria collapsed in
the civil war
worried about putting their money so
close to the conflict investors started
pulling out of lebanon's banks
but the scheme didn't fully unravel
until 2017
when lebanon's prime minister
disappeared i hereby announce my
resignation as prime minister from the
lebanese government
knowing that the will of the lebanese is
stronger and their determination is
steadfast
the sunni prime minister saad hariri
resigned via a televised statement from
saudi arabia
then reports claim the saudis forced him
to resign and were keeping him there
nothing has justified the apparent
detention of hariri
by saudi arabia sadal hariri and his
family
are hostages in the kingdom after 10
days the prime minister returned to
lebanon and took back his office but the
damage had been done
this time international investors lost
faith in lebanon and deposits plummeted
even lebanese residents rushed to pull
their money out of the banks
without new deposits the governments and
bank's debt skyrocketed
in 2019 the banks ran out of money and
froze accounts limiting what people
could withdraw
leaving lebanon's people with a
catastrophic problem
and people can't take out their dollars
and they can't import or what they do is
they hike up the prices
so now all these goods that are imported
are now extremely expensive they're
talking about
um life-saving medicines basic
healthcare equipment
grain shortages fuel as well
to cover its debt the government
announced a new tax sparking a
revolution
lebanon is in the grip of unprecedented
protests the anger was sparked by the
government's announcement of a daily tax
of 20 u.s cents on messaging
applications such as what's up
to many it was evidence that the whole
system was corrupt
and people from all sects flooded the
streets in some of the biggest protests
lebanon had seen in decades
and so the uprising was really about
eliminating this ruling class of
political party which divide
little and working-class people based on
sec but at the top they just
shared a slice of the pie together so a
lot of people realize that
this has got to go there is the new way
of doing politics
it was enough to force prime minister
hariri to finally step down
but the political parties stayed in
power meanwhile other countries and
international organizations offered
economic aid to lebanon
if the government could reform itself
but the politicians couldn't agree
and the economy kept falling apart in
one year lebanon's currency lost more
than 80 percent of its value
and unemployment has reportedly surged
this was the state of the country when
an explosion rocked beirut
well at first it appeared to be an
accident the blast turned out to be the
result of this dysfunctional system
according to reports the ammonium
nitrate sat in the port for seven years
while government officials bickered over
who was responsible for it
it's criminal negligence at best they
knew what this was
they knew what it meant and yet this
material
it was left to language and beirut
sports
prime minister hassan diyab and several
ministry leaders resigned
but the power sharing agreement remains
intact it's why many in lebanon feel the
country can't recover until this system
is abolished
[Music]
to make matters worse there's been a
spike in coronavirus cases since the
blast
and now with its only major port
destroyed in the explosion lebanon is
struggling to import what its people
need to survive
and while all of the political
leadership is paying lip service to
the catastrophe that has befallen beirut
no one really seems to be taking much
action it's left the lebanese people to
simultaneously demand for change
and pick up the pieces there are people
on the ground
helping residents pick up their lives
clean up
rebuilding and this is all a personal
[Music]
initiative
you